Oh
when I was a schoolboy in Glasgow I
suppose I was treated to the usual
smorgasbord of historical subjects that
most British schoolchildren study a few
weeks of the Romans a few weeks of
ancient Britain's some Scottish history
and then it became a little bit more
serious the Wars of the Roses the reign
of James the sixth and first what was
then called the English civil war or
revolution but these days they call
something much fancier like the British
civil wars plural and I studied the 19th
and 20th centuries at school - I'm not
sure all of these different things were
terribly well connected but I did find
myself drawn more and more to the
subjects but the older I got and the
turning point I think was the year and
I'm guessing my age was 15 or 16 when I
was studying Hamlet in English
literature and the 30 Years War in
history now the the study of the play
Hamlet is something that everybody
should undertake and I still have fond
memories of the essay I wrote on the
theme of death in Hamlet but when I was
studying the 30 Years War I was
encouraged by my history teacher Ronny
woods to go to the Mitchell library
which is a wonderful library in Glasgow
and I went in in search of books on the
30 Years War and was absolutely stunned
to find an entire shelf of books on the
30 Years War the first of which was by
Friedrich Schiller the great German
student hang dramatist and historian and
it was the realization that there were
so many different ways of thinking about
the 30 Years War as opposed to the one
play of Shakespeare called Hamlet that
that
shifted my my attention from English to
history
historical study differs from a great
many other things saved the whole realm
of social sciences for two reasons first
they were not engaged in model building
we're not trying to simplify the world
of human beings into some kind of
mathematical model historians live and
breathe the complexity of the past and
we accept that there really is a sample
size of one there's only one human
history and we can't rerun us in any
laboratory so we can't be engaged in a
scientific underside if ik endeavour the
second thing that that history does is
that it encourages that minority of
human beings who are alive I think it's
only 7% of all the human beings who ever
lived who are alive right now
to understand what the other 93%
experienced in their time so historians
build a bridge backwards through the
generations and at the heart of our
enterprise is the imagination one has to
imagine what it was to be in another
time in another predicament and that
active of imagination is at the heart of
the historical process the great
philosopher RG Collingwood said that
we're engaged in reconstructing past
thought on the basis of those remnants
that other civilizations leave behind
the letters the documents that that's
really what history is so this
combination of understanding complexity
and reimagining past life seems to me to
be a tremendously valuable combination
of skills reliable more reliable in my
view than more formal forms of social
science as a way of understanding the
futures plural because there's no such
thing as the future singular they're
just multiple futures we all
simply get to choose or at least we we
we try to choose and it's the
combination of our decisions that
produces the one future that happens
I've become more more convinced with
every passing year that as an historian
I'm in a stronger position to imagine
plausible futures than somebody who's
trained in another discipline often
thing else knowing at least some of what
happened to the last that the the dead
93% of humanity just gives me more
scenarios to draw from trying to think
about the futures requires a certain
amount of thinking by analogy and if all
you've got to go on is your own lifetime
experience plus some model I think
you're likely to get it wrong whereas
with historical understanding of past
scenarios you're probably going to be
better at visualizing futures than the
competition and that I think is an
extremely powerful argument for the
study of history not just by people who
want to be professional historians but
also by people who want to be good
citizens good decision-makers good
scenario builders
colleague at Harvard Kenneth and his
co-author Carmen Reinhart have
identified the four most dangerous words
in the English language as this time is
different in their book of that title
which is the subtitle eight centuries of
financial folly they show how often
human beings have persuaded themselves
that they live in a special time and
that the rules of the past no longer
apply and that therefore the price of
housing the price of stocks you name it
the price of tulips can can rise forever
this this allusion in the financial
world has all sorts of analogues in
other spheres there are those who will
assure you that we live in a unique time
with respect to communications or with
respect to military force now my strong
belief is that for all the technological
change that has happened over the last
200 or so years and particularly the
technological change of the very recent
past this time is not so different from
previous times that we've nothing to
learn from the past just to give one
example I'm having this conversation
with an anonymous to me unidentifiable
audience through the miracle of a
digital camera and the internet now
that's certainly very different from the
way in which Martin Luther can
communicate his ideas about Christianity
to the German public in the early 16th
century the way that happened was
through sermons which of course could
only be heard by hundreds of people at a
time but were then communicated via the
printing press and and transcriptions to
a much much larger or larger audience
the Reformation came about in the 16th
century because of a network effect
there was a viral quality to it and the
printing press was to the Reformation
what the internet is to our time
understanding how networks operate is it
tremendously helpful thing for
historians to be able to do but the
thing you learn is that the important
thing about a network is not the speed
at which the information travels whether
it takes days or nanoseconds is not the
important thing
the important thing is that the network
should exist and that it should have
network properties that should be
positive externalities if it reaches
enough people no matter whether it's in
days at all or nanoseconds that can
change the world so for me the most
important thing to recognize is that
although technology may speed the world
up and it may make networks much larger
than they've been in the past it doesn't
change the essential property of a
network
when I was a boy and in fact to this day
my favorite television superhero was not
the Superman or Batman or spider-man or
any of these people to turn this
physical power it was a gentleman named
Doctor Who a BBC character who I think
is is unique or perhaps shares the
distinction with Sherlock Holmes alone
of being an intellectual superhero not
distinguished by any physical prowess
but but distinguished by his
intellectual firepower Doctor Who is and
forever shall be a Time Lord
that's his designation he has the
ability to travel through time and he
was my hero because it seemed to me that
that ability to travel through time was
something far more appealing than the
ability to stop a locomotive or hold up
a following tower block or whatever it
was that Superman was able to do stop a
speeding bullet
so doctor who appealed to me because
time seemed to me to be the really
interesting thing to have power over
that the study of history is is all
about time for example in the project
that I'm currently working on which is a
provisionally titled history of the West
and the rest
the rise of the West to predominance
after around 1,500 time plays a key role
the Chinese had clocks elaborate
hydraulic water clocks well before West
Europeans had anything like that but
when at West Europeans began to build
mechanical clocks which they they
initially needed to get the timing of
church services right a revolution began
which was characterized by the rapid
dissemination of smaller and smaller
timepieces the Chinese are these huge
clocks they were pretty accurate but
they never had watches they never had
clocks that you could just put in your
living room and so I'm fascinated by the
technological revolution of the clock
and the
because of course that that transformed
the precision with which Westerners
could live their lives the David Landers
wrote a wonderful book on this the great
Harvard economic historian that but it's
it's it's still a neglected classic I
wouldn't say it was absolutely central
to the way that histories is studied but
for me clocks are crucial I spent some
time a few weeks ago in a shop in
central London which specializes in
antique clocks grandfather clocks
there's big ones that that you see in
old country houses and a certain kind of
old-fashioned living room and had a
wonderful time discussing with a clock
enthusiast the different styles of clock
that came from the different regions of
the British Isles in the 17th 18th and
19th centuries so time is something that
I have long been obsessed with and I
suppose I've come to realize that that
power over time was one of the things
that made the West ascend to dominate
the rest for most of the last half
millennium
if you had been dr. who if you were
Doctor Who and you took a trip in your
TARDIS back to the year 1500 or 1400
somewhere around about the 15th century
you would have been very impressed by
Beijing probably the biggest city in the
world at that time with its clean wide
streets it's dazzling palaces you might
also have taken a trip on the Grand
Canal connecting it to Nanjing the older
imperial capital you would have been
very impressed by what you might have
seen of the Mughal Empire in India
you'd have been dazzled by the
achievements of the Ottoman Empire and
what is today Turkey these great
oriental empires would have would have
really knocked your socks off and if
you'd had time to take in Peru you'd
have thought the Incas had something
quite impressive going on and the Aztecs
in Mexico too you then take a trip to
London and you would have been very
underwhelmed by this town because it
wasn't a city it was quite small then it
was very smelly and dirty because the
sanitation standards were way lower than
then in Asian cities you wouldn't have
been that impressed by the architecture
because apart from the Tower of London
most of it was pretty rudimentary London
Bridge was about the most impressive
thing there so you certainly would not
have put money at that point on London
and other West European cities becoming
the dominant entities of the next 500
years something happened that empowered
the ramshackle little monarchies of
Western Europe to become the masters of
the world the economic masters the
technological masters the political
masters something made these little
countries they were little countries
Portugal England the Netherlands and
then there's somewhat bigger Spain and
France something empowered these
countries
and enable them over a period of time to
establish mastery over the much larger
empires of the East as well as over the
entire new world as they called it than
the Americas and so I've been asking
myself a lot for the last few years what
that was and the course that I've been
teaching recently at Harvard had the
title Western ascendancy mainsprings of
global power which is a somewhat
bombastic title but gets to the heart of
the matter what was it that made the
West dominate the rest while the
Westerners superior to the rest honors
if you will forgive that phrase and I
I've come to the conclusion that there
were really six killer applications
killer apps that's originated in the
West which it took ages for the rest of
the world to download and for the sake
of brevity I'll tell you that what the
six were imagined bullet points so
number one was competition both
political and economic to talk about
capitalism misses the point that that
Western Europe also had phenomenal
competition between multiple
institutions in the political sphere two
autonomous cities you really didn't find
in in the great Asian empires but the
fact that London was a semi-autonomous
City in medieval England and that within
London there were multiple corporations
and guilds representing different crafts
it was really a very distinctive feature
of that society it was partly a
consequence of the weakness of royal
authority that there was no emperor in
Europe as powerful as as the Ming
Emperor in China
Charles v tried and ultimately failed to
establish a monopoly on par so
competition is part of the story
unquestionably the Scientific Revolution
that happened in the 17th century is
killer app number two Newton had no peer
no competitor in the eastern world much
less in the Americas although the Asian
empires had mathematics to a very high
level and astronomy though that
sometimes blurred into astrology
they just didn't do the scientific
revolution and they were effectively
offline when the Scientific Revolution
and as it did in in Western Europe with
some traffic to North America
number three killer app well one might
say democracy but I think that would be
wrong because most Western political
institutions were not democratic in the
strict sense until relatively recently
late 19th century early 20th century
it's more that an idea of citizenship
based on property ownership and
representation took hold first in the
english-speaking world and then it it
spread john locke was in many ways the
great theorist of this relationship
between property and representation and
the idea of some property owning
representative government spread from
England to North America and in the
United States found its most perfect
form when this became democratic when
the franchise was extended and on
property owners democracy was much more
likely to work where that foundation
existed it was the rule of law in a
system where the law was made by
property owners through a representative
assembly so that's killer at number
three number four is modern medicine
that one once the West figured out what
caused cholera epidemics or why plague
spread or water percolo saswat antigen
for the rest and so in the late 19th
century into the 20th century there's a
revolution in human life expectancy
which is entirely the result of advances
in the realm of medicine and the great
empires of the late 19th century early
20th century used this knowledge to good
effect but so in a some was a brutal way
because inseparably allied with these
medical advances was a pseudoscience of
race that essentially legitimized
Western imperial power by asserting that
non-western peoples were subordinate
forms of humanity that's the shadow side
of this story I'm telling which I want
to emphasize because this is not a
triumphalist story it's an exercise in
comparative history killer at number
five is the consumer society the idea
that everybody should have more than one
set of clothes and that sounds rather
banal unless you're a teenager in which
you immediately guess it but but it's
usually important once you have clothing
at the heart of your economy textiles
textile factories which were the key to
the Industrial Revolution in England and
everywhere else you need consumers to
and the big difference between spices
and clothes
spices were the basis of the Dutch East
India Company's business and clothes
textiles were the basis of the British
East India Company's business is simple
the demand for clothes and spices like
nutmeg is finite it's quite inelastic
there's only so much that you can
consume a year the demand for clothing
is infinitely elastic the there is never
enough in your wardrobe in it seems to
be in most human lives and so textiles
and the Industrial Revolution that
accompanies the spread of the consumer
society really represents killer app
number five and finally Max Weber had a
brilliant idea about a hundred years ago
a little bit more that there was a
Protestant ethic that generated the
spirit of capitalism now I think he was
sort of half right about that because a
work ethic clearly was something that
differentiated the West from the rest
for much of the period I'm talking about
where he was probably wrong was
attributing this exclusively to
Protestantism because it turns out that
many many different religious cultures
can get that work ethic Jews had it
roughly contemporaneously with
Calvinists and nowadays of course what
we see is that work ethic spreading into
all kinds of different civilizations
most notably the Confucian civilization
of China so the argument is a six-part
argument there are six killer apps that
give the west predominance over the rest
over about five hundred years and the
final question of course is is it over
is this the end of Western ascendancy
and it seems quite plausible to think
that it is because after all these
killer apps are no longer mont
monopolized by the West the rest
basically have downloaded them all to
varying degrees but with a pretty high
degree of success and that means it's
unlikely that the West will continue to
occupy that position of extraordinary
predominance that it had say a hundred
years ago when maybe 20% of people in
the world lived in Western empires
Western society
but they accounted for more than 50% of
all global income I think that that's
pretty much coming to an end now
it still seems plausible to me that
these institutions I'm describing
determine success or failure at least in
the realm of economic growth and
political stability the interesting
thing is the most rapidly rising
non-western power of our time which is
the People's Republic of China has
adopted most but not all of the killer
applications so they've certainly
downloaded competition that the economy
of China is a planned economy at core
but it has a market economy wrapped
around that they have of course
downloaded science and there's no
barrier to non Western societies
engaging in scientific research today
modern medicine for sure it was an
interesting feature of communist regimes
that they were quite good at using
modern medicine to improve welfare for
large populations the consumer society
well they're getting there it's been a
saver society until recent times but it
is now policy in Beijing to encourage
consumption among ordinary Chinese and
to make China less reliant on exports to
Western consumers and as for the work
ethic well they have that in in spades
it's a an extraordinary phenomenon that
the people who work the longest hours in
the world today are in fact in East Asia
and not in the West the the one killer
app they haven't downloaded is of course
our political model with its emphasis on
private property rights and
representation of the individual and I
don't think they're going to it's pretty
clearly policy in Beijing to have five
out of the six off-the-menu but but not
that a crucial third killer app which
ultimately produces democracy so we're
running an interesting experiment which
is to see whether it's actually
dispensable if you're from Singapore if
you're Lee Kuan Yew you think it is and
it's clearly the Orthodox view in East
Asia today that you can have all these
different aspects of modernity you can
have these Western institutions but you
don't need the political one you can
have it on the basis of enlightened
Authority
and I have to say that I'm a little
doubtful that that will turn out to be
right because we we ran this experiments
actually within the West because we had
free societies in the West and we had
unfree societies the West generated lots
of alternatives to itself one was
communism the other was national
socialism and these alternatives failed
and pretty dismal a actually it seems to
me and here I'm really following their
work of the great Nobel laureates Doug
north the the institutions of freedom
political freedom and economic freedom
are indispensable for an innovative
society that you can have science
without freedom but you probably can
have scientific innovation you can
replicate what they do in the Western
laboratories but are you actually going
to have the real breakthrough I think
you have to have the full range of
freedoms to be as innovative as say the
United States has been over the last
hundred years
let's take another trip back in time
it's 1936 and you decide to go on a trip
to the Soviet Union and you're welcomed
by your hosts and taken on a tour of
some absolutely spectacular construction
sites
perhaps you go to Magnitogorsk this
sudden eruption of industrial
architecture in the middle of nowhere
and you you are deeply impressed by what
you see you see skyscrapers in Moscow a
city transformed and you come back to
New York and say I've seen the future
and it works of course at that time the
capitalist Democratic model looks pretty
badly broken you've just passed three
years since the trough of the Great
Depression and it's by no means clear in
1936 that the United States is out of
economic trouble there's a great deal of
unease about the way in which Western
democracy functions all over Europe that
Democratic regimes are falling because
of the lack of belief in the democratic
model most notably in Germany fast
forward to now you take the same trip
you go to Shanghai maybe you go to
Chongqing further up the Yangtze and you
see most spectacular construction site
you come back and you say I've seen the
future and it works it's just a few
years since the failure of Lehman
Brothers and the collapse of the Western
financial model and wherever you look
there is disquiet about the way the
democratic process works it's at its
most acute in countries like Greece but
only because Greece is further down the
line of fiscal crisis than the other
Western countries today so there are
reasons today why you might make the
same mistake that George Bernard Shaw
and Sidney and Beatrice were made when
they went to the Soviet Union what what
they got wrong was that they judged by
the surface the degree to which
a truly alternative model had been
established they did not see or chose
not to look at the shadow side a
standard system which of course included
a vast network of prison camps the gulag
in an atmosphere of terror in which no
individual including members of Stalin's
own family could feel safe China today
is not Stan and Soviet Union body means
the levels of coercion and terror are
far lower and the degree of economic
freedom is far higher but it is still a
planned economy right at its core
Chongqing is not being built into the
biggest and fastest growing city in Asia
all by market forces it's the result of
a command economy run out of Beijing and
there is an absence of political freedom
that is very real indeed for those who
choose to criticize the system now we
should therefore be careful what we wish
for when we start applauding the Asian
model and denigrating our own I'm in the
front line of people who are critical of
the way that the United States has
handled public finance over the last
decade and it seems to me that there is
an urgent need for a radical reform in
that area before we end up in a
greek-style mess but we've got to be
really careful here to distinguish just
as distinguished between epiphenomena
the way in which taxes are raised and
public expenditures are managed and the
core phenomenon of our constitutional
order based on individual liberty and
free expression that constitutional
order is way way more important than any
of the that the outlying issues of
fiscal reform and it is a superior
constitutional order than anything else
available in the world today and I still
feel convinced that the experiment of
organizing an industrial society without
a representative form of government will
fail as it has failed everywhere else
that it's been tried in the past because
as I've said the Chinese are not the
first to attempt breakneck
industrialization
political freedom
a parallel that I've drawn recently
which isn't to everybody's taste is
between China today and Germany a
hundred years ago let me emphasize a
hundred years ago not in the 1930s in
the 1910s hundred years ago Germany was
one of the most dynamic societies in the
world it had a rapidly growing economy
it was leaping ahead of Britain in terms
of industrial innovation it had already
by 1910 the best universities in the
world much better than the American
universities at that time incidentally
and it was also a country filled with a
self-confidence that was shading into
arrogance as Germany rose the hegemony
of an english-speaking Empire Britain's
was obviously called into question and
that was something about which the
Germans became more and more explicit
cars of elohim ii was somebody who had
an uncanny ability to put his foot in
his mouth but much of what came out of
that mouth about germany's ambitions to
have a place in the sun to have a world
policy a global policy to have an empire
and a navy comparable in the sight in
size to those of britain those were
things that ordinary Germans believed in
- not all of them but many when I look
at China today I see a similar
combination of rapid economic growth
impressive innovation social
transformation but also a political
system that doesn't want to change that
what's essentially to retain the
institutions of 40 years ago which is
essentially what the Kaiser wanted - and
I also detect a real resemblance in the
somewhat shrill nationalism that
emanates from some parts of Chinese
society notably from relatively young
Chinese it's it's it's university age
Chinese who produced these rather mad
patriotic videos whenever they feel that
china has been slighted whether it's
over
Tibet or Google or whatever so there's a
vilhelm on policy but
that it takes a historian to spot and
they're doing wilhelmine stuff they're
terribly interested in natural resources
in Africa check check that box
they're building a much larger Navy than
they've ever had before check that box
they're somewhat strident be challenging
the rights of an english-speaking Empire
to call the shots around the world tick
that box and so on so it seems to me
that the big challenge that the United
States faces is very similar to the
challenge that Britain faced a hundred
years ago it's a it's a dynamic rival
it's a rapidly growing rival it's
starting to beat you on a number of
different things it's producing way more
qualified engineers than than you are
and what you don't want to admit to
yourself is that this thing is is not
going to be in a comfortable symbiotic
relationship with you indefinitely
Germany was certainly in that kind of
relationship with Britain in the 1870s
and 1880s trade between Britain and
Germany flourished there was all kinds
of cultural exchange but it's not a
stable marriage if one rival is growing
faster than the other it is a rival not
a partner and we're living in that
transition today I think it's not exact
historians work with rough analogies not
with perfect matches and there are all
kinds of differences of which the
cultural difference is perhaps the most
important the cultural difference
between the United States and China is
vastly greater than the cultural
difference was a hundred years ago
between Britain and Germany even shared
members of the same royal family as
their monarchs but I think if you look
at the key elements the relationship has
much in common the economic element the
strategic element and above all I think
this nationalist dimension which is
going to become more and more of a
feature I think of relations between
China and the United States
there are two things to remember about
that the relationship between China and
the United States one is that the
demographics are about to turn against
China quite sharply the the Chinese
because of the one-child policy in the
in the more years and subsequently have
a really serious demographic imbalance
between the generations and that is
going to become a major problem as the
proportion of Chinese aged more than 65
soars in the next two decades they also
have a huge gender imbalance and there
are some provinces in China where male
children are 20% more numerous than
female children because of selective
infanticide and so forth the second
point to remember is that the financial
nexus between China and the United
States is profoundly unstable I've
talked with my friend Moritz Schiller ik
for three years now about Chimerica the
fusion of China and America in the
economic sphere and at the heart of that
fusion was a kind of vendor finance
where the Chinese lent us the money to
buy their stuff and they did this out of
self-interest at the same time the
Chinese accumulated vast quantities of
US dollar denominated securities to keep
their currency from appreciating and
that currency policy has produced a
mountain of claims on the rest of the
world international reserves in excess
of two point four trillion dollars some
70% of which are in the US dollar form
it's not stable because the Chinese
don't want this mountain to get any
bigger they've come to terms I think
with the fact that their currency must
strengthen in the years ahead and
they're looking for alternative routes
to go down because if they just stay on
this course that they've been on for the
last ten years it's pretty obvious
what's going to happen that their US
dollars are nominated claims at some
point are going to become worth much
less because the obvious way for the
u.s. to get out of its financial
difficulties is for the dollars of
weaken and foreign claims in the u.s. to
become worth less so we are at a fork in
the road it's now I heard a Chinese
economist two weeks ago say
our policy now is to buy no more US
government securities and not to sell
all that we have at the same time now if
you think about what that means the end
of reserve accumulation by China and
possibly a gradual winding down of
Chinese exposure to US securities it
means the end of a credit line to the
United States that has been worth there
not a lot to American consumers and
American investors it means that the
Chinese support for US government bond
prices is going that means their price
will drop which means that US interest
rates will conceivably rise and that of
course will act as a real dampener on US
recovery prospects when it happens and I
believe it is happening now so the big
problem for the u.s. is realizing that
this relationship is unwinding when I
hear American policymakers talk about
this I still hear the same riff that I
was hearing two or three years ago they
need us as much as we need them they
can't dispense with us as an export
market so they're not going to risk
destabilizing this relationship I heard
that just the other day at Harvard's
Kennedy School and it's profoundly
complacent and wrong the Chinese don't
think of it this way these they see this
as a marriage on the rocks and they are
actively looking if not for another
partner then certainly for a divorce
from this somewhat unreliable and
spendthrift American spouse
as I said earlier there are many futures
and we don't know which one will happen
but there's no doubt that a quite
probable future
looking ahead ten or twenty years has
the United States as the waning Empire
crushed under a burden of debt
accumulated in a relatively short period
of time no longer as economically
dynamic as it's been in the past perhaps
also played by internal political
dissension and on the other side a China
that appears to have found the magic
formula to achieve 10 percent growth
year after year a China that is not only
content with economic predominance but
starts to to crave a strategic power at
least in in the asia-pacific region that
takes the form of of a submarine fleet
aircraft carriers deepwater ports that
future is a plausible one because
similar things have happened in the past
and we would not be entirely surprised
if an english-speaking empire began to
wane suffered from economic
underperformance and was challenged by a
rival empire to the east which was
achieving sustained higher growth rates
it's one future but I want to leave you
with another future but that is a little
bit more cheerful in this other future
of the United States because it still
has a political institutional advantage
addresses its own internal problems
achieves quite radical fiscal reform
streamlines its tax system cuts the
entitlements that are about to bankrupt
it rejuvenates its its politics and
embarks on a new era of optimism
propelled forward by the technological
innovation and entrepreneurship there
are still properties securely strong in
the United States if the United States
can use its advantages both political
and technological and
entrepreneurial to grow its way out of
this crisis that it's currently in then
the futures rosio for Western
civilization at the same time in this
alternate future China starts to bump up
against the kind of weaknesses that the
hormone Germany also encountered the
social dissension in Bill Hamid Germany
was really one of its defining
characteristics the Social Democratic
Party became the biggest party in the
German parliament in 1912 and this was a
Marxist party explicitly hostile to
almost every aspect of the German regime
so that there's a sense in which one can
imagine things going wrong in China and
going right in the United States history
isn't one simple predictable narrative
it isn't governed by the laws of physics
or anything resembling them there's a
huge uncertainty about what happens in
both these countries not to mention the
rest of the world which is what makes
the study of history so in here it'd be
fascinating it's not linear there isn't
some nice predictable curve that tells
you about when American power will
decline and and when Chinese power will
ascend it's a very nonlinear chaotic
complex process that we as historians
get to study and that's why when we talk
about the future we should correct
ourselves and say futures plural and
here are the futures we have to choose
from